if you weren't already convinced that
Carol Baskin from the hit Netflix TV
show Tiger king is responsible for what
happened to her then-husband on Lois
well by the end of this video you will
be absolutely certain that she is
responsible for his disappearance and by
disappearance it's been real we're
talking about his murder
because I did some digging and I
couldn't believe what I found and in
this video I'm gonna share with you two
separate examples of new information
that was not included in that show that
is so incredible it will likely make
your jaw drop I'm not kidding
now on this channel most of my videos
are on ancient civilizations however
I've also discussed in different videos
conspiracies ranging from JFK to Nikola
Tesla and other topics as well in fact
even some of my earliest videos on this
channel involved making a murderer and
blackfish so now that I've been cooped
up in my house for the last few weeks
with my dogs because of the ongoing
coronavirus lockdowns I just can't help
myself but to make a video that exposes
a real-life murderer especially
considering that Netflix is adding a
brand-new bonus episode to the tiger
King series which airs tomorrow Sunday
April 12th but before I share the
bombshell new information this be real
most people are already convinced that
Carroll Fukien Baskins did it just from
watching episode 3 of that Tiger King
series literally everyone in Don Louis's
entire life thinks that he was murdered
and Carroll did it even his own kids and
his ex-wife are completely certain that
Carroll is involved in fact let me quote
gladdy Lewis Don Lewis his ex-wife as
she said the last day I saw Don he told
me that he was done that he was
divorcing her and that Carroll was one
of the worst people he ever met in his
life and that she was very dangerous
even Don's old business associates
Wendell Williams stated that the very
last time he saw Don Lewis Don had told
him that he was going to tell Carol that
he wanted a divorce and Wendell went on
to say that Don was preparing his estate
and assets and sets away they D could
get a divorce from Carol without losing
everything in fact he said that he
or that it was his impression that Don
thought that Carol was there only for
the purpose of getting his money which
was what Don was trying to protect and
then boom Don went missing forever
think about that the very last time he
saw him that's what Don told him and by
the way that was even corroborated by
Kenny Farr who was Don's longtime
handyman he said that Don was setting up
for a divorce in a way that Carol would
have got nothing she would have lost all
the big cats been left with no money
even losing the house in the car in the
process so think about that after 16
years of marriage and being humiliated
as Don cheated on her left and right
which no one denies and then to be left
with absolutely nothing that sounds like
potential motive to me
and when you consider what Carol wrote
in her own diary which Joe xotic somehow
got a copy of which is pretty hilarious
I'd like to know how he got that but she
did say and I quote I listened while he
told me that all of his money and
everything urine by himself and brought
into this marriage by himself was his
and she went on to say that I wish there
was some way out for me if that's not
suspicious enough then he mentioned what
mark McCarthy who was another business
associate of Don's stated that one month
before Dawn's disappearance Don had told
him that he felt that his life was in
danger
Jesus and if that's not enough witnesses
look at what Ann McQueen stated who was
Don's executive assistant who many
considered to have been his most trusted
person that Don knew as she was
literally in charge of all of his assets
and not only that he trusted her so much
that she was his power of attorney if
that's not trust I don't know what is
but get this and stated that not long
before he disappeared
Don started to act funny and the very
last time that she saw Don alive he gave
her an envelope that had a piece of
paper in it and Don told her that she
needed to take it home and keep it safe
adding that if anything ever happened to
him she needed to give the envelope to
the police well it turned out that
inside that very envelope was a copy of
a restraining order that Don had filed
on Carol Baskins barely two months
before his disappearance the restraining
or
stated and I quote this is the second
time Carol has got angry enough to
threaten to kill me going on to say that
Carol got into a big fuss ordered me out
of the house or she would kill me and
adding at the end in parentheses
she has an h5 revolver and she took my
357 and hit it
Don filed that restraining order in June
and in August he went missing and was
never seen or heard of again
Wow right and and if that's not enough
the fact that everyone in Don's life
thinks that he was murdered and that
Carroll did it I didn't even mention the
Dons old lawyer Joseph Fritz thinks that
Don was indeed murdered and if you
watched the series it could not have
been more obvious that he thinks Carroll
is the one who did it although he
refused to say it but again if all of
that isn't enough let me now get to the
two bombshells that I mentioned earlier
which brings me back to the restraining
order you may be shocked to hear that
the restraining order the Don Luis filed
against Carol was not the only
restraining order ever filed against her
we all know that Carol is now married to
good old Howard Baskin they met in 2002
and were married in 2004 but before she
met Howard Carol had another boyfriend
named Jay Baykal who lived with her and
in 2002 at the end of their relationship
Jay filed a restraining order on Carol
stating that he feared for his life
that's right and you can even see the
police reports online for yourself in
fact I'll put a link in the description
of this video
Jay wrote that he was in fear of danger
of serious bodily injury or death going
on to cite Carol's missing ex-husband
who was presumed dead and that Carol was
a suspect in that case Jay goes on to
write that he asked Carol what happens
when her missing ex-husband Don shows
back up and Carol replied dead bodies
can't talk oh my lord he even goes on to
write that even Carol's Daughter Jaimie
warned that Carol is dangerous and that
he should watch his back and if all of
that isn't crazy enough in the same
paragraph he mentions that when human
bones were found by the authorities
behind some local RV
Carroll had said that she hopes the
bones were not found on her property
otherwise she would be in quote deep
[ __ ] now I looked up that RV Center
wondering if it neighbored her own
property but it appears to be more than
25 miles away from Big Cat Rescue that
is unless the location moved in the last
20 years or if Carroll once owned
property by this RV Center either way
I'd be curious to know more from J but
isn't that nuts a second person who had
an intimate relationship with Carroll
filed a restraining order on her at a
fear of their own life filed an actual
police report went to that extent and
one of who of which went missing forever
that's what you would call a red flag
but if that's not enough let me go on to
bombshell number two as we know Carroll
had a husband before Don Lewis and his
name is Michael Murdock who she had a
daughter with as well named Jamie as I
mentioned earlier it turns out that John
ranky who you'll recognize from Tiger
King as Joe exotic zoo manager had an
interview recently with David Spade on
his podcast and what he said made David
Spade's jaw drop and I'm not gonna lie
what he said made my jaw drop as well
because I couldn't believe it he said in
reference to Carol's husband Don being
missing that and I quote she's missing a
husband from before that - she has a
really deep past and there's some things
that haven't come out yet in the
episodes you can go watch that interview
yourself in fact I've included a link to
Speights podcast for that video in the
description but are you kidding me
is that true is Carole's first husband
Michael Murdock actually missing but
this is a real question and I'll be
interesting to see if this is mentioned
in the brand new episode that comes out
tomorrow but think about that this guy
right here look for yourself guys
Michael Murdock does anybody know if
this guy still exists is this man alive
because he is one of three husbands that
Carol has been married to and one of
which is gone forever
obviously so this guy is he still around
I mean just think about all this add it
all together I have to ask is Carol
Baskins
a black widow this is a serious question
is Carol Baskin a black widow think
about
he'll Carol even referred to Don Luis as
venomous in her own diary saying that
she hopes that her daughter Jamie never
finds herself in a sick and perverted
relationship like that one just think
about that word venomous have you ever
used that word or do you know anyone
that's ever used that word to describe
somebody I mean yeah we have words like
[ __ ] and you know manipulator
narcissist that's a good one you know
but of all the words to call somebody
venomous it's kind of funny especially
coming from a potential Black Widow so
again when you consider all the details
provided by witnesses that nude on
including family multiple business
associates and everyone else and how
they all thought that Carol killed them
and when you consider that Carol had a
second husband that's possibly missing
and the pattern of multiple lovers
filing restraining orders on her you
have to ask yourself what's really going
on with her and let me just say I do not
think that Howard good old Howard Baskin
is in any immediate danger whatsoever
because that's be honest and this is not
meant to be mean but Howard is clearly a
beta and something tells me that it's
the Alpha is that Carol doesn't like I
mean come on down Lewis is clearly an
alpha who probably slept with hundreds
of women or at least as many as he
possibly could it seems like no one
seems to deny that and yeah so Carol
despised him accordingly I don't even
blame her but when it comes to Howard I
think he's totally safe I don't think
she would hurt a hair on his head unless
he ever decides to leave her because the
thoughts of his submissive beta love
attention going to another woman oh my
that right there will probably be way
too much for Carol to possibly handle
and then she'll dust off that old
missing 357 magnum revolver and maybe
she'd give one to a good old Howard as
well poor guy I don't I think he thinks
that she's totally innocent guys I'm not
gonna lie he's just man he's a victim as
well but out of all the things shared in
this is I'm not a lawyer but is this not
enough information to at least issue a
new warrant to search her property I
mean it would be a total crime for this
investigation to just not go anywhere
with all the existing evidence that's
there I mean this reminds me of OJ
Simpson I mean it couldn't be more
obvious on who did it so yeah it'll be
interesting to see but the good news is
that law enforcement the sheriff in that
area has said and reached out to the
public saying that they are looking for
new tips and leads on this case in fact
Don's old lawyer who I mentioned earlier
Joseph Fritz was recently interviewed
since the series had aired and stated
that he would like to work with law
enforcement in providing his knowledge
to help solve the case so here's a
question for law enforcement to ponder
on Carroll says that Don had simply had
dementia and he wandered off and by the
way everyone that he knew says he did
not have dementia or at least from the
research I found but if that was the
case if he was losing his mind and he
had just wandered off and got lost as
Carol had claimed then why did she wait
two days to call the police when he was
missing if your husband had dementia and
he just got lost you would wait two full
days doesn't add up does it now going on
let me talk about Joe exotic I think
there's a lot of things that could be
said about this guy and he is
undoubtedly guilty of more than one
thing but I would argue that although
he's done some terrible evil things he's
not necessarily an evil person at heart
I mean he's certainly a next-level
egomaniac and a massive narcissist no
doubt but there is something to say
about the way his big cats loved him and
it's interesting that Joe never got
mauled to death after all those decades
spent so closely to them or to him and
you know many cat people will tell you
that felines have outstanding sense in
differentiating from good and bad people
and I bet anything that if you put Carol
into the same exact enclosures with the
same exact lions and tigers that Joe
xotic interacted with I think that they
would pounce on her immediately I think
they'd go for her neck and I'm not
kidding I'd bet on it
you know Carol even claims that she's
allergic to cats now but you know what
something tells me she just says that as
an excuse to not interact with any cats
at all because did pounce on her and I
think she knows it I could be wrong but
hey all I know is that she is one
massive hypocrite at what she's done a
big cat animal rescue let's be real
anyways guys I'm gonna leave it at that
I'm Jimmy my
channels called bright insights and I'm
excited to see the new episode that
comes out tomorrow and I hope you guys
will watch it too I mean this show is so
odd it's so ridiculous but you could say
that it's hilariously riveting there's
something about it where it's like well
I can't turn away I gotta watch it but
anyways guys I'm working on my other
video a few weeks ago an Instagram I
posted that I was working on a fun and
thought-provoking video when I was
almost done with it but when the
lockdowns went underway my routine got
destroyed and my attention when else
we're looking into kovat and watching
this freaking tiger king' series and
everything else and I kind of put pause
on that but the good news is is that I'm
almost done so expect that in about a
week or so we can half maybe give or
take but it's coming soon and it's very
thought-provoking and I know you guys
will enjoy it and then after that I'm
working on another video involving a
potential cover-up involving our ancient
past so look forward to those videos and
this anything else comes up and the
headlines before that I could always put
something else in its place but yeah
I'll leave it at that
again I'm Jimmy channels got bright
insight hit the like button and
subscribe if you haven't and leave a
comment share what your thoughts are on
all of this what do you think about
Carroll or do you think about Joe exotic
and all the rest of this all I know is
that this is a fun topic because it's a
frickin television show and something to
keep our minds entertained while going
through these lock downs but I hope
you're all doing well I'll leave it at
that
see y'all real soon take care everybody